Marcus Swanson, Filmmaker and LA Film School
Student: You spoke in the beginning about
the rapid change in the industry causing problems.
I wanted to know if you think students should
try to keep up-to-date with things that they’ve
previously learned if by the time they graduate
it will already be kind of evolved?
Houston Howard, Transmedia Author and Instructor:
One hundred percent. Everything changes so
fast that now it’s incumbent upon creators
not just students but professionals especially
professionals that have been in the industry
awhile. The typical 30-year screenwriter that
has seen and done it all they find it difficult
to really want to stay on top of things.
I think students naturally because of the
generation they have grown up multi platform
and they’ve naturally learned all of the
new platforms and learn all the new stuff.
I think now we live in such a crazy, oversaturated,
technologically advanced time that really
if you want to stay relevant you need to figure
out how to utilize and maximize and leverage
the new platform, the new touch points and
methodologies that audiences are using every
single day and it’s not necessarily because
the theater is going away or Netflix is ensuring
that everything streams. It’s not necessarily
that. I always put it in reference to the
audience. If you understand your audience
and you can design to your audience then you
are going to be a better creator. And if you
start to see audiences operating on multi-platforms,
if you see audiences really gravitating into
podcasts. Podcasts are very big, they are
very popular today whereas two or three years
ago not as much. But if you see a big push
into podcasts then all of the sudden that
should clue you in that there is an opportunity
to the platform but in the mindset of the
audience.
Once you start to understand that audience
you will be able to take that psychology and
lace it through how you are going to create
your IP [intellectual property].
I think a lot of the new platforms with mobile,
with podcasts, with like Alexa, Google Home,
all of that stuff. I think understanding how
that is starting to shift culture. Why are
people starting to use voice? Why is voice
coming back? It’s almost like we are coming
back to a 1930’s radio era.
I think that instead of being threatened by
that that creators, screenwriters, directors,
authors they should recognized that and leverage
that as a tool into those things.
What I typically get is is “Well I don’t
know how to make a podcast?” “I don’t
know how to make an Alex skill. I don’t
know how to do any of that stuff.” Like
you can’t teach old dogs new tricks. I just
don’t believe that. I tell people there
is this amazing website that teaches you how
to do anything in the world and it’s called
G - O - O - G - L - E [dot] com. You go there
and type in “How do I make a podcast? How
do I create an Alexa Skill? How do I do something
on IGTV? And you can spend 7 or 9 or 48 hours
reading and learning how to do all of this
stuff and now all of the sudden you have an
extra skill on your Batman belt as a screenwriter
not necessarily to augment it in a way that
is flowing in line with culture and that I
think is flowing in line with culture and
that I think is empowering rather than threatening.
I’m a big advocate of never stop learning
especially as a creator because if you never
stop learning you are always going to be in
line with your audience.
How do we differentiate between transmedia
as a marketing strategy compared to like a
storytelling strategy? Should I be using transmedia
in my storytelling or is it just a marketing
ploy?
Houston: Historically bad transmedia has been
rooted in marketing and what happened and
what happened (nothing against marketing)
marking is not a bad term, it’s not a pejorative
term but where transmedia breaks down is when
creators push transmedia off to the marketing
people and really don’t understand the story
or they don’t have the right to extend the
story. So a lot of times you will see a marketing
heavy transmedia pushes that are light on
story and are never about just trying to exploit
the media and create and entry point for the
audience and there isn’t a valuable extension
of the story.
For me the best transmedia flows through the
creator into all these touch points where
now the mobile game and the Facebook live
and the IGTV series they are not just marketing
tools, they are storytelling tools and the
big difference is how much story are you getting?
Is it story first or is it just promotional
first?
The more promotional it is the less valuable
it is to the audience. I always liken it to
me and my wife have two dogs. We love our
dogs…we are like weird dog people that love
our dogs too much. And so I always use the
analogy that you need to feed your audience
and feed your fans like you feed your dogs.
That is the first lesson that you learn as
a kid with a dog is that you need to feed
your dog every day, it’s your responsibility
(that’s what my dad told me). He said if
we’re getting a dog, you are going to take
care of it, it’s your responsibility to
feed it every single day. And creators need
to have that same attitude when it comes to
their fans. It’s their responsibility to
continue to feed the fans. Don’t put it
off onto a marketing person, to a publicist
or to other people (to PAs or interns). You
need to understand this as a creator how do
I feed my audience? Which then begs the question
what’s the best food to feed the audience?
The best food to feed the audience is story.
As a GAME OF THRONES fan the best thing you
can feed me is a GAME OF THRONES story. Not
necessarily a GAME OF THRONES trailer or commercial.
I’m excited about those things but they
are like sugar rushes. So if you eat a bunch
of sugar, if you feed you dog just a bunch
of junk, if you feed it a treat, it may get
excited but that’s not going to nourish
them over the long term.
So the thing that nourishes the audience the
most is just honest to God just good story.
If you tell me as a GAME OF THRONES fan that
there is great story delivered on Instagram
I don’t care that that is Instagram, I go
there for the story. And I consume that story
and now there is a brand equity that continues
to strengthen in me through the GAME OF THRONES
brand in general because they fed me and the
more you feed you audience the more loyal
they are.
Because if you don’t feed your dog what
happens? They either die, they go somewhere
else for food, they turn on you and eat you
like Ramsey Bolton (that’s a GAME OF THRONES
reference). But anyway you cut it or your
neighbor who has the food lures them away.
So now in an oversaturated market you have
all these people saying “Hey I’ll feed
you over here! I’ll feed you over here!”
And now there’s competition in the marketplace.
So for me the thing that differentiates marketing
and transmedia is what kind of food are you
feeding your audience? Is it story or is it
just promotional. And if the creator is involved
and it’s part of the creative vision, it’s
more likely than not be more story than it
is promotional. As soon as the creators disconnects
and hands it off to the digital marketing
people they may call it transmedia but it’s
probably just going to be a big marketing
plot.